IT REALLY DOES BRING OUT THE
BEST OF AMERICA, BUT I WANT
TO BRING IN NOW, A FRIEND, A
COLLEAGUE, SOMEBODY I SERVED
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS, THE FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA, AND I
BELIEVE A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
TREY GOWDY.
TREY, I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
YOURSELF, TEARING YOURSELF OUT
OF BED.
WE GAVE YOU THE LATEST POSSIBLE
TIME THAT WE COULD, I WAS
SURPRISED THAT YOU ACTUALLY GOT
HERE THIS EARLY BUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU, JASON.
THE DRAFT KEPT ME UP LATE LAST
NIGHT BUT I MANAGED TO GET HERE
BY 9:30.
>> JASON: SO I WANT TO GET TO
POLITICS AND STUFF GOING ON IN
THE WORLD TODAY BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP IS BLASTING THE DEMOCRATS
CORONAVIRUS AS HE CALLS IT "
WITCH HUNT."
HERE IS AN  ANTHROPOLOGY EXCERPT
FROM THE TUMULTUOUS CAMPAIGN
E-MAIL.
HE SAYS FIRST THE DEMOCRATS
RUSSIA COLLUSION DILUTION FAILED
BECAUSE WE FOUGHT BACK AND THEN
THEIR IMPEACHMENT HOAX FAILED
BECAUSE WE FOUGHT BACK EVEN
HARDER AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING
TO WEAPONIZE A NEW CORONAVIRUS
COMMITTEE AGAINST ME, THIS IS
THE THIRD WITCH HUNT IN THE
THREE YEARS.
IF THE PAST HAS CAUGHT US
ANYTHING IT’S THAT THEY’RE
PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO TURN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AGAINST ME
ARE NOT GOING TO WORK.
I USED TO CHAIR THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, YOU WERE THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND
NOW THEY WANT ANOTHER COMMITTEE
IN CONGRESS TO GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT AND LOOK AT
CORONAVIRUS?
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> WELL JASON, LET ME PHRASE IT
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN UNDER
INVESTIGATION SINCE BEFORE HE
WAS THE PRESIDENT.
ITS BEEN FOUR YEARS NOW.
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION BEGAN
IN THE SPRING OF 2016, SO FOR
FOUR YEARS DONALD TRUMP HAS
BEEN UNDER INVESTIGATION.
I’M GOING TO LIST FOR YOU THE
NAMES OF THE PEOPLE LEADING
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS AND I WANT
YOU TO STOP ME, JASON, WHEN I
GET TO SOMEBODY YOU THINK IS
REALLY FAIR, AND PETER STRZOK,
LISA PAGE, ANDY MCCABE, JAMES
COMEY, JOHN BRENNAN, ADAM SCHIFF
, JERRY NADLER.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
INVESTIGATED BY THAT CREW?
SO UNFAIRNESS EITHER THE REALITY
OR  THE PERCEPTION OF UNFAIRNESS
HAS A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THE
PERSON WHO THINKS THEY’RE BEING
TREATED UNFAIRLY AND SO TRUMP IS
WATCHING THIS NEW COMMITTEE BE
FORMED TO INVESTIGATE HIS
RESPONSE.
HAVE YOU SEEN SCHIFF HAVE A HEAR
ING ON MICHAEL HOROWITZ’S
FISA REVIEW?
HAVE YOU SEEN SCHIFF HAVE A HEAR
ING ON CHINA’S RESPONSE TO
COVID-19?
NO IT’S ALL TRUMP SO IF HE
APPEARS PARANOID SOMETIMES YOU
CAN BE PARANOID AND PEOPLE
REALLY ARE OUT TO GET YOU.
PETE: AND TREY, JUST LIKE IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY, THEY WERE
OBSESSED WITH IMPEACHMENT WHEN
THEY COULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
FOCUSING OR  PAYING ATTENTION TO
THINGS NOW AFFECTING US NOW.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED YESTERDAY,
HE SAID THE DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS
ARE SPENDING MUCH ON THEIR MONEY
ON FAKE ADS.
I NEVER SAID THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS IS A HOAX BUT
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE WAY THEY
LIED ABOUT IT ARE A HOAX AND
ALSO IT DID START WITH ONE
PERSON FROM CHINA AND THEN GREW
AND WILL BE A MIRACLE END.
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON HOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS HANDLED THIS
UNDER SIEGE, STARING DOWN
THE CHINESE, PRESS BRIEFINGS
INFORMING THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
WHAT’S YOUR SENSE OF HIS HANDL
ING SO FAR?
>> WELL THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED EVENT IN OUR
COUNTRY, AND IT’S HARD TO BE A
LEADER WHICH IS WHY SO FEW
PEOPLE RAISE THEIR HANDS AND SAY
I ACTUALLY WANT TO BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
MY ADVICE TO THE PRESIDENT IS TO
LET THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS HANDLE, EXPLAINING
OUR HEALTH CARE RESPONSE.
HE SHOULD BE THE COMFORTER IN
CHIEF, THE ENCOURAGE ERIN CHIEF,
MIX IN HOPE WITH A REALITY OF
THE STATISTICS, BUT LET THE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
HANDLE GIVING US ADVICE ON HOW
WE SHOULD TREAT THIS VIRUS.
IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING TO FEEL
LIKE YOU’RE CONSTANTLY THE
OBJECT OF UNFAIR CRITIQUE
BUT ITS BEEN THAT WAY FOR FOUR
YEARS AND I DON’T THINK HE NEEDS
TO PUNCH DOWN THE INDIVIDUAL
REPORTERS DURING THESE WHITE
HOUSE BRIEFINGS.
LET THE DOCTORS HANDLE THOSE
QUESTIONS, BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT’S AN INCREDIBLE HONOR VERY
FEW PEOPLE WILL EVER HAVE SO
DON’T PUNCH DOWN THE INDIVIDUAL
REPORTERS AS TEMPTING AS IT MAY
BE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU MENTIONED A
GREAT POINT, TREY IN THE FACT
THAT THE PRESIDENT DOES LIKE TO
SPEAK OFF THE CUFF DURING THOSE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFINGS BUT
THAT’S PART OF THE REASON WHY HE
WAS ELECTED IN 2016 BECAUSE
AMERICA LOVED HE SPEAKS TO THEM
BUT UNFORTUNATELY HE DOES GET A
LOT OF CRITICISM BECAUSE HE
LIKES TO SPEAK OUTLOUD AS DR.
BIRX HAS SAID BUT I
DON’T UNDERSTAND THE DICHOTOMY
OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE SAYING THEY
ARE GOING TO INVESTIGATE THE
TRUMP ADMINITRATION AND HOW
THEY HANDLED THIS WHEN THEY ARE
CRITICIZING HIM THAT HE NEEDS TO
LET MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
ACTUALLY HANDLE AND FIELD THESE
QUESTIONS AND WHAT THE TO DO.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS JUST
MORE DIVISIVE THAN ANYTHING
THAT’S GOING ON RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE’RE STILL IN THE MIDST
OF COVID-19.
WE’RE NOT PAST IT.
WHY DON’T THEY ACTUALLY GET TO
WORK AND PUT SOMETHING FORWARD
TO ACTUALLY HELP LIKE THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND INSTEAD OF HAVING
DELAYED AND GETTING LOANS OUT.
HAVING THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN MY
OPINION IS JUST ANOTHER WASTE OF
RESOURCES AND PEOPLE POLITICOS
TIME AND GOING TO TAKE ATTENTION
AWAY FROM WHAT IS REALLY NEEDED
RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, DR. SAPPHIRE THE
NICEST COMPLEMENT I COULD
PAY YOU IS YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND THE WAY WASHINGTON
REACTS.
YOU’RE A HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL
WHO JUST SEES A PATIENT AND
DOESN’T CARE IF ITS A REPUBLICAN
OR  DEMOCRAT JUST TREATS THE
PATIENT.
THAT’S NOT THE WAY WASHINGTON
WORKS.
THEY WANTED THIS PRESIDENT UNDER
INVESTIGATION SINCE THE DAY OF
HIS INAUGURATION AND THEY WANT
HIM UNDER INVESTIGATION UNTIL
THE NEXT ELECTION, AND THEY’RE
GOING TO DO IT AND DO IT WITH
THE AIDING AND THE A BETTING OF
THE D.C. MEDIA.
WHERE IS THE SCRUTINY FOR NOT
HAVING HOROWITZ TALK ABOUT FISA
ABUSE?
WHERE IS SCRUTINY FOR ADAM
SCHIFF FOR NOT HAVING HEARINGS
ON CHINA AND WHAT THEY DID WITH
COVID-19?
IT IS ALL TRUMP ALL THE TIME SO
IF HE APPEARS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MIFFED AT FOUR YEARS WORTH
OF INVESTIGATION I THINK THAT’S
THE REASON.
JASON:  NOW CONGRESSMAN I WANT
YOUR TAKE ON VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WHO HAS DENIED THE
ALLEGATIONS OF ANY SEXUAL IN
PRO PIETY BUT I’VE DOT TO TELL
YOU THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THIS CASE SAYING HOW
COME THE MEDIA IS NOT ASKING JOE
BIDEN ABOUT THESE QUESTIONS THE
WAY THEY INQUIRED WITH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH?
>> WELL JASON, LADY JUSTICE
WEARS A BLINDFOLD FOR A REASON
THAT’S PROBABLY THE LAST SYSTEM
THAT’S UNIVERSALLY RESPECTED IN
OUR CULTURE BE THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BECAUSE YOU DON’T SEE  R
OR   D AND YOU DON’T SEE
NORTHERNER OR  SOUTHERNER.
YOU JUST SEE THE FACTS.
I WAS REALLY CRITICAL OF
POLITICIANS DURING KAVANAUGH.
HOW COULD YOU POSSIBLY SAY,
JASON SAY I’M GOING TO DECIDE
WHO I BELIEVE BEFORE THE PERSON
OPENS THEIR MOUTH?
DO YOU REMEMBER DEMOCRAT SENATOR
S SAYING ALL WOMEN MUST
BE BELIEVED?
WELL THAT SURE AS HELL WASN’T
THEIR POSITION WHEN I WAS
PROSECUTING RAPE CASES AND THEY
WERE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COURTROOM.
THEY DIDN’T THINK ALL WOMEN
SHOULD BE BELIEVED, SO I WANT
EVERYBODY TO BE TREATED THE SAME
JOE BIDEN IS ENTITLED TO DUE
PROCESS, THIS VICTIM IS ENTITLED
TO TELL HER STORY AND THEN WE’LL
USE CROSS-EXAMINATION AND THE
CONFRONTATION OF WITNESSES
THAT’S THE WAY WE GET THE TRUTH.
WE DON’T DO IT BY SAYING ENTIRE
CATEGORY OF WITNESSES ARE TO BE
BELIEVED OR  DISBELIEVED.
THAT’S NOT THE WAY OF THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKS OR  THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM SHOULD
WORK.
PETE: TREY GOWDY, SMART DUDE.
WE MAY DISAGREE A LITTLE BIT.
I’D LIKE TO SEE THE PRESIDENT
SMACK BACK AT THESE PHONY
REPORTERS BUT I GET YOUR POINT
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US
THIS MORNING, THANK YOU SO MUCH.